[Music]
all right let's go to glenn in macon
georgia what's up glenn
hey what's going on guys first time
caller here all right we sound like
first time
first time radio host so what's up
so i have a question so i just i i
discovered um the baby steps uh you know
like literally a week ago and i'm you
know all hands in my wife as well
welcome hey welcome to our gang man
welcome to the game thank you
thank you thank you um so i have a
situation that i wanted advice on so uh
first and foremost a look back around
myself i'm active duty military
um and i'm going to be leaving in
a couple in about six months to go
overseas on the tour for a year being
away from my for my uh family i have
about forty five thousand dollars in
debt right now the biggest one being our
car loan now the issue with that is
is that when i first i was originally
stationed in england for a number of
years and i came back uh stateside when
i came back my credit was terrible and
we ended up getting this car it was at
the end of the day a bad deal but we had
the car for a number of years and then
all of a sudden the uh the engine goes
out
and when we took it back to the
dealership and they basically put us in
a new car we carried over the negative
the the negative equity on the car
um so now i'm basically i started off
the the loan starting off paying thirty
seven thousand dollars on a car this
value pretty much was at twenty one
thousand even brand new and i wanna know
what should i do
with that car should i sell it should i
try and go for something cheaper should
i keep going with it since it is such a
reliable car and again i'm not gonna be
here uh and my wife is gonna be the main
one using it
does she have another car to get around
uh no
okay so if you sell this thing if if you
were to go take out a loan for the
difference sell this thing
and clear everything you're gonna have
that loan note of the gap plus you'd
have to go get another car too
exactly do you have any cash
i don't like i said we are step one and
you know
yeah we were in in heavy heavy debt what
kind of car is this tell me it's
incredible
it's it's not incredible i mean it's a
good car it's a
2021 kia forte okay
we got it back at the end of 2019.
um again it's very very reliable we have
no issues with it uh i love why my wife
loves it but if we need to make the
tough decision to you know sell it or
give it back or whatever to go into a
cheaper car we will that's right so
what's the loan amount currently
uh right now i have uh about 30 000
months to pay on it okay and you're
saying it's worth 21
yeah according to kelly blue book
okay
i'm gonna do some homework on that and
go check every single car website
carvana of room whatever they are
dealerships facebook marketplace
craigslist and see if you can get closer
to 34 it's so that there's less of a gap
okay and when you when did you say
you're getting deployed
uh january january okay so we have from
now until then to save up as much cash
as possible work as hard as possible get
side jobs what is your household income
yeah
so i'm renting right now right now my
apartment i rent at 1085 but this month
at the end of this month our lease is up
and they've already hit us with
uh our rent is about to go up due to how
the market's doing so we're going from
1080 right 1085 to about 1500 bucks oh
what what's your what's your take home
what's your salary you and your wife
come back
so i'm the only one working right now my
wife is a student um uh it looks like
that she's european so a lot of the
places because she's going through the
uh uscis process a lot of the places
aren't gonna yeah like they'll hire her
but at the same time because we can't uh
update her or renew her her visa or
anything until the month of her
expiration
you know they they see her as unreliable
can i just say dude i'm so sorry they
have to go through that
i've i worked with students
so much extraordinary brilliant
wonderful students
also trying to earn money to eat with
while they were being students here
and it's such a maddening insane process
and then you top it off you've got
somebody who's dedicated his life to
serving
our
just dude
on behalf of you know that i know that's
wrong too okay and it makes me mad too
that's not going to help you do anything
but kelly it's ridiculous man so
frustrating could you get a job on
campus
that's been the only way around it that
i've seen
so so with her it was she
she's the real trooper in the family uh
because when she's uh for she's from
spain
um and you know she had already had uh
done all her heights she was already in
college in spain when we met when she
came over here to the states with me
after you know we got married and had
our daughter
uh her college credits wouldn't transfer
right over here
and the process to even transfer them
it's like the amount of money that we
have to pay is enormous
hey hold on hold on
check with a couple of schools on that
is she are you all too far down the road
yeah well like i said um so my wife
ended up starting from square one in
earning again her american high school
degree here and she's about to be done
with everything another enter school
over here because again the military at
least pays for all that okay um but yeah
she started from square one high school
all over again in the languages she's
not used to and she speaks five
languages so it's just like wow all this
wasted potential for so long just
because she didn't have the correct
credit yep okay glenn what's the other
15 in debt you said you have 30 on the
car loan what else
yep uh
one loan that i'm almost done paying off
of uh next year long and the russians
and credit cards
okay
and you didn't tell me your income what
is that what's your take-home pay every
month
uh
about four thousand
okay
can you see if there's other apartments
that will rent to you for closer to what
you were paying
i could try but again it's gonna like
you know with me moving so soon i'm not
even sure if it's gonna be worth it at
the moment where she's gonna live the
reason we
she's gonna say he stay here in the same
in the same apartment that i'm gonna
have because you know as soon as i'm
done with this store this one you talk
we're gonna be moving to some place
completely different where the military
is gonna be sending me i have no idea
yet can she roll into base i know it's
not ideal but you can save you a whole
bunch of money while you're gone and
give her some community too
that that is that is an idea the only
thing that we're afraid of is taking our
daughter out of a school system that
she's really thriving in yeah that's
fair and if there's not if i mean i i
get that
um man i'd love to see y'all knock this
dead out though
yeah i know right now i'm even for the
next six months i'm looking at picking
up like i've heard you guys say and some
of the other shows you know pick up a
secondary job some delivering pizzas
like i need three man but i'm selling
this car you're gonna have to go to your
local credit union take a loan out for
the difference but try to make that gap
as short as possible stack up as much
cash as you can get her a car clean this
mess up before you head out that's the
best thing to do for your family